the more somebody's put time into
something, the less likely they are to
abandon those uh those efforts. And so,
putting this into practical application,
when I was trying to get people to run
my malware, whether it be over the phone
or through email, I would always make it
difficult on them to run the malware
because the harder they had to work to
run it, the less likely they were to
notice any red flags. And uh and I think
in that that first instance where I told
you about that I I talked money into a
bank vault. If you Google how to rob a
bank uh over the phone, you'll find a
black hat talk that I gave uh years back
um at Black Hat Europe. But in there, I
play real audio from this social
engineering call. And uh and it it just
really uh stood out to me how easy it is
to get people to do stuff and how when
they've invested time, they just won't
ignore stuff. And so the the example is
he runs my malware the very first time
and his anti virus triggers and says,
"This is malicious. Do not run it." And
uh and because he had spent so much time
and energy trying to get it to run in
the first place because like I said, I
make it hard. Uh he ignored the anti
virus triggering and just bought my
excuse hook, line, and sinker. And we
continued to run applications on his
computer for the next two days.
[Music]
Joshua Crumb, welcome to the human zero
day. I'm really really happy to have you
here. I' really been looking forward to
this episode. Thank you for joining me.
>> Yeah, thank you for inviting me. It's
it's a pleasure to be here and uh
talking social engineering or layer 8
that that's my favorite thing to talk
about. So excited to dive in.
>> Well, uh with more than 20 years of
experience in cyber security today,
you're the CEO of Fish Firewall. um
you've been a at the at the the shoes of
the hacker before of the social engineer
uh pentester
um now with the perspective of also
founder and CEO and looking at the
market more broadly. So, I'm I'm really
excited to to piece together this market
with you across these different layers
and go all the way into the eyes of the
social engineer and and the techniques
and the psychology of it and then
climbing up gradually uh towards the
market and and what's happening in the
world around us today. Joshua, help me
first understand how you got here. How
does one find themselves involved in
this amazing space?
Uh well, you know, it it I think for me
a lot like many others, I first learned
about this through the the many
underground 2600 groups. Um that's how I
I guess I I stumbled across it. Learned
a little bit about hacking before there
was a thing called ethical hacking. Um
got scared. Uh didn't really want to uh
end up in jail for using my skills bad.
Um, but I I actually ended up getting
sued way back in 2001 for hacking. Um,
and uh, and that was like a wakeup call
for me. Uh, so I switched and actually
went into marketing at that point. Was
like, okay, I I I'm going to stay out of
this. Don't want to uh, spend any of my
life locked up. So, I'm going to I'm
going to be uh, you know, be good. And
uh, and I spent like six uh, or maybe it
was even closer to eight years. Uh but
six or eight years in marketing, that's
actually what I went to college for. Um
which really did help out with social
engineering because marketing is that
offensive social engineering practice.
How do we get people to do what we want
them to do? And so so much of marketing
is behavioral science and and how we
apply it. And uh and so it made me very
naturally good at social engineering.
And when I I first got into the industry
and uh after I'd spent a few years in
marketing, I was asked by this uh the
company that I worked for cuz I was very
technical still even though I was in
marketing. And they said, "Hey, any
chance you could hack this Excel uh
password protected Excel sheet for us?"
And I'm like, "I don't know. I'll look
into it." And in the process of looking
into it, stumbled across this tool at
the time called Backtrackk Linux, which
is now Kali Linux, and that's like the
pen testing platform. And that led me to
realizing that penetration testing was a
a very viable career. And uh and so I
decided that day to quit my job. I I
went in, I talked to the CEO of the
company that I was working for. Uh told
him a little bit about where my mind was
at. He said, "Honestly, we've uh, you
know, we've been really moving more and
more out of retail and into wholesale
where we don't need as heavy of a
marketing department. I think it's great
timing. I'll give you some severance so
that you got time to go out and study
and, you know, jump hit the ground
running in the new career." And uh, so
with that, I I that same day, it was my
last day that I worked there and uh,
ended up going on cyber. spent the
entire time just studying and learning
cyber security and more importantly
ethical hacking. Uh was terrible. So I
got a job with a terrible company about
3 months later. Uh but within 6 months
after that I was working for one of the
top teams in the country. Um and about a
year after that I was running the uh one
of the top red teams in the country. And
so I just it was where I I think I was
always really meant to be because
security came very naturally to me. Um,
but that's also why I started this
company was because I saw that we had
some major flaws in our industry and we
weren't addressing them. And uh, and I
just felt like there was almost a little
bit of insanity happening where we just
keep repeating the same thing over and
over again uh, and expecting different
results and then wondering why we
continue to fail.
>> I I love it that it sounds like quite a
journey. If you if you go back to the
early days of learning the ropes and
going from an okay mediocre to an
excellent social engineer and and
ethical hacker, is there some story or
some event that really comes to mind?
Some memorable experience that that you
recall fondly that that you'll be
telling your grandkids in uh in years to
come?
Uh well, there's a lot of them, but I I
actually think one of the more telling
ones was my very first physical
engagement. Uh and so this was right
after I had jumped from a terrible
company to a really good company or one
of the best in the the world. And uh and
so I had never I I'd done a lot of like
external penetration testing and web
penetration testing previous to this,
but I hadn't had that opportunity to
physically break in or do social
engineering. And so on this assessment,
uh I'm quite literally able to talk my
way into a bank vault. It all starts
with uh talking to somebody over the
phone who should have known better
because they were warned that hey,
somebody's going to call you up on this
day and try and get you to do stuff
you're not supposed to do and then on
this day they're going to show up in
person and try and get to you to do
stuff you're not supposed to do. Um and
but yet the same guy completely falls
for it. Hook, line, and sinker. And I go
from, hey, I'm going to be a very
technical hacker where, you know, I'm
never going to use social engineering
over to the dark side in an instant. And
I said, oh, this social engineering
stuff's really fun. Turns out I'm really
good at it. I want to continue to do it.
And it just kept going on like that. Uh,
next assessment was a Fortune 500 data
center. The one after that was a casino
money cage. and uh and almost getting to
the point where like you know in just my
first few assessments I accomplished
some of the most hard to do social
engineering feats and uh and it it
actually got me in my head for a while
like how am I going to top this?
>> Incredible. So So Joshua, why do humans
fall for fishing? What what's happening
here? I mean we I mean we're we're we
should be skeptical na skeptical
creatures by nature. It's all about
survival. How do we how is it that we're
falling for these fishing scams?
>> So, humans
regularly and most of the time without
any consciousness of of this happening
use these little mental shortcuts called
cognitive biases to quickly make
decisions. These cognitive biases are
things like, hey, if a letter comes in
from the CEO, I better prioritize it and
move quickly. Um, or it might be, hey,
if uh if all of my peers are saying that
this is really great, it probably is
great. Um, or even just the sunken cost
fallacy, which is uh where the more
somebody's put time into something, the
less likely they are to abandon those uh
those efforts. And so putting this into
practical application when I was trying
to get people to run my malware, whether
it be over the phone or through email, I
would always make it difficult on them
to run the malware because the harder
they had to work to run it, the less
likely they were to notice any red
flags. And uh and I think in that that
first instance where I told you about
that I I talked my way into a bank
vault. If you Google how to rob a bank
uh over the phone, you'll find a black
hat talk that I gave uh years back um at
Black Hat Europe. But in there I play
real audio from this social engineering
call. And uh and it it just really uh
stood out to me how easy it is to get
people to do stuff and how when they've
invested time, they just won't ignore
stuff. And so the the example is he runs
my malware the very first time and his
anti virus triggers and says this is
malicious. Do not run it. And uh and
because he had spent so much time and
energy trying to get it to run in the
first place cuz like I said, I make it
hard. uh he ignored the anti virus
triggering and just bought my excuse
hookline and sinker and we continued to
run applications on his computer for the
next two days.
So cognitive biases making us irrational
that brings me back to a I used to work
with a professor Danelli who wrote
predictably irrational and I'm I'm fully
convinced that we humans are irrational
creatures.
I was also unfortunately convinced that
that as irrational creatures,
it's a the real way to defend ourselves
is to create an environment around us
where we don't put ourselves susceptible
to these biases. Yet there's a big part
in fighting fishing and social
engineering which is about teaching us
and training us to fight these cognitive
biases, become aware of them in the
moment and be able to act differently
than our intuition says. What what is
that about?
So I believe in social engineering for
good. Uh this there was this moment in
my career where I had tailgated in off
of the exact same person four years in a
row uh to gain access to highly
sensitive and restricted areas of one of
the country's largest financial
institutions.
And I just felt disheartened. I mean, at
first it was high fives and laughing and
then it was, well, why why are we doing
this? If we come in every year, we issue
a report and nothing happens and that
person doesn't even learn that they made
the mistake so that they can prevent it
from happening again and four years in a
row I can come in off the same guy,
we're not providing any value. And I
didn't just get into
so ethical hacking just to have fun. I
also wanted to make a difference in the
world and uh and help stop these these
criminal organizations from growing
because when we look at the top
ransomware groups, they are are
generating more revenue than Crowd
Strike and they've got margins that are
astronomically higher uh than
CrowdStrike, which means they are better
funded and more capable sometimes than
even nation states and attacking us. And
so we've got to stop that from
happening. We got to stop funding them.
Well, when you look at our industry,
everything's reactive. Uh almost
everything assumes compromise. And we
put so little of our effort into those
proactive parts of defense and our in
our strategies. And so I thought, hey, I
think we can use social engineering for
good. And a few things that stood out to
me, well rewinding before that, uh, when
I got into this, it really turns out
it's not social engineering, it's
behavioral science. We've studied this
in depth and it's just not been applied
to cyber security. In the process of
that, I got invited to speak at a few
academic conferences. Uh, met some
professors that were writing uh,
coursework for exactly this. How do we
build effective security awareness
training programs that not only address
compliance but change behavior? And uh
and so I I got the opportunity to work
with professors from around the globe on
on writing this college coursework and
uh and really just more importantly
sharing and exchanging ideas on how we
think this can apply. And so all of that
comes back around to our body has a
natural built-in uh antivirus or
whatever you want to call it. And uh and
there's this really great book called
Thinking Fast and Thinking Slow. And it
talks about how we have a fast brain and
we have a slow brain. Love it. Yes.
Okay. Um I can tell uh you're you're
definitely likeminded if you got that
book right behind you. Um, but in there
it talks about how we have this fast and
the slow brain. And the fast brain is
it's our instincts. It, you know, helps
make sure that we block our face if
something's flying at it or that our
eyes close if it's a something's about
to hit our eyeball. Well, it can also
defend against uh cyber threats because
our subconscious and our fast brain does
not care what the threat is. It's
designed to be very adaptive to any type
of threat. So what that means is we got
to focus less on education and getting
people to consciously avoid these
attacks and more on conditioning and
getting people to subconsciously avoid
these attacks. And uh and you do that by
repetition and hands-on learning and uh
and so it's called a col's experimental
learning cycle but it talks about how
when we can give somebody a hands-on
experience they learn better. And then
there's this other behavioral science
principle called identical elements
theory that starts to kick in. Um,
identical elements theory talks about
how once you learn about something
really well, you'll see it everywhere.
The example is when you buy a new car
and you think you're one of the more
unique people in town with your car
pick, but then you drive it off the lot
and you see that car at the very first
stoplight and then you see it at the
next stoplight and you start seeing it
everywhere. That is identical elements
theory in action. But I uh not only
hypothesize but have the data to show
that it works. Um have been able to
prove that we can implant human virus
definitions by running fishing
simulations and making sure that at the
moment they they mess up, they realize
their mistake. They've got really
strong, really effective just in time
training. And now all of a sudden they
learn about, you know, how to hover or,
you know, the sense of urgency being
used against you. And when they learn
that, they'll start to recognize it
across all mediums. It doesn't matter if
that tactic is used in email or in a
text message or even in a voice phone
call. Uh they're going to notice it and
they're going to see it everywhere. And
so to me, that's how we change our
people from being the weakest link into
being our greatest asset. But it starts
at a subconscious level. And I really
think it also starts with us training
people in grade school, not waiting
until they're adults and they're, you
know, the most susceptible group of in
our uh company is the youngest people,
by the way, right now. Um I think we got
to start training them to be more secure
at a young age. the same as we train
people to stop, drop, and roll if they
catch on fire or the same as we train
people to look both ways before they
cross the street. And to me, that is how
we effectively change it. I know long
answer.
>> Was so so was that one of the
inspirations for the book protecting
your family from hackers?
that
>> absolutely I think that uh when people
realize that cyber security is
interconnected and that those same
skills that they're being taught to
protect their uh the their employer and
their paycheck also apply to protecting
their families at home. it means more to
them. And it goes from, you know,
protecting this, you know, rich
corporate entity that they probably
don't care as much about as they say
they do, uh, to protecting their parents
from elder scams and things like that.
And that's something they do care about.
And so it's it's connecting it and and
when you do, you get an emotional
response. And when an emotional response
happens, whether it's connecting things
back to home or the realization of a
mistake, there's a chemical reaction
that takes place in the brain, which is
quite literally creating new neural
pathways. And so, if we make sure that
there's really good education at the
moment that that emotional reaction
happens, we can actually get much much
higher retention rates. Uh but it's also
the reason that I continuously tell
people, you know, we're in an industry
filled with introverts and we all have a
call to calling to be extroverted.
Whether you want to or not, if you are
in cyber security and you're not talking
to every department, you're failing
because that's how you understand your
risk better and that's how you build
allies and that's how you get people to
come around. And so I truly do feel that
there's this need for more marketing to
be brought into cyber security and and
and not just as a whole but training
even specifically. Look at ads from
Coca-Cola. They're 10 seconds long.
They're 15 seconds long. At most they're
30, but they're not 5 minutes or 10
minutes or 15 minutes long. And that's
the training that we're doing. And when
you put it into perspective and you
think, well, okay, I'm going to shrink
all my training down to under a minute.
Well, now I can be in your inbox every
single week of the year training you
about different cyber security topics
and not even waste an hour of your time
over the course of a total year. And
it's a very big difference from what
we've been doing where they forget about
it almost instantly because we gave them
too much information at once and it's
too infrequent.
Well, AI is uh very much transforming
the landscape, isn't it? And I I heard
you
>> I I heard you talking about that um on
on your podcast quite a bit. So, I'm I'm
I'm really looking forward to hearing
and getting deep into into what's
happening here. Um, like I mentioned to
you, I've I've been experiencing the
generation side of of AI through my
academic studies and uh and just
considering the implications of of the
usage of these AI generated media in the
context of social engineering and
fishing. It's kind of scary to say the
least. It's it goes in from from the
emails with bad spelling to all of a
sudden you have perfectly written Chad
GPT style narratives all the way to
potentially real time impersonations on
voice calls on video calls. H So walk me
through the transition that you're
seeing yourself from your eyes as AI
creeps into the world of social
engineering and fishing. And then I'd
love to to just to hear also what are
what does this mean in terms of the
expectation from people experiencing
that.
>> So you know with what we do we're able
to and and do a lot of experimentation
on both the offense and the defensive
side of AI. Um, from the offensive
perspective, uh, we've realized that
these large language models are
incredibly good at linguistics.
And what that means is that when I give
it a cognitive bias and I tell it to
exploit this cognitive bias and create
an email around that, it's better than
almost any human that I've ever worked
with in my uh, ethical hacking or my my
red teams. Um so if we can train it on
understanding how to exploit those um
the opposite side is we can train it to
identify those same cognitive biases and
in fact we've got a product coming out
uh sometime in uh probably early to mid
Q2 of 25 called fish GPT and that's
exactly what it is is it's a secure
email gateway that looks at the
underlying psychology or cognitive
biases that are being utilized in that
email to detect on whether or not it's
malicious. Um, it's a very different
approach than everything else in the
market that is looking at technical
indicators like how long has this domain
been registered? Do we know who it is?
What's the domain reputation?
And then a bunch of other stuff more
specific to the email like the actual
tactics they'll use. You know, do we
have a bunch of empty spaces at the top
of the email that indicates it's
malicious? uh do we have an email thread
going back and forth about uh you know
with the same group of people and then
all of a sudden we see this email thread
that has all that old stuff in there but
to a new group of people. So while those
technical indicators work, it's a cat
and mouse game because they're endlessly
changing and the bad guys are always
adapting. The one part of fishing and
social engineering in general that never
changes though is the psychology. So,
I'm really motivated by how can we
utilize the AI's ability to understand
psychology to better protect against
these types of attacks and even when
we're not sure to warn the user and help
train them better. Hey, this could be
malicious. It uses urgency. Be very
careful before you click on any links.
And so to be able to drop in those
dynamic and and context or contextually
uh accurate bits of advice I think are
are going to really help us in the
future. Uh but AI is is changing things
and it's changing things rapidly. Um I
was playing with the uh the new version
of uh Sunno uh I think version 4 over
the weekend. Um and it's just
phenomenal. I can create these highly
complex songs in a minute less than a
minute. It takes like 30 seconds and uh
and you can create the potentially the
next hit and uh I I'll play you some
later if if you want. It's some fun
stuff. But you know just staying on top
of AI like it's changing our world I
think more than people understand.
Medical is advancing at a rate we've
never seen before. And in fact, they
predict that sometime in the 2030s,
we're going to surpass the uh longevity
escape velocity, which just is fancy
words for we're going to be able to live
forever.
And and Joshua AI is not just changing
the attack the attack sophistication
across text, right? I mean, this the
it's changing also the modality within
which we live. there not just text now
it's also voice and video is that also
the same psychology or are we going to
now see new forms of tactics and
circumstances in which people fall to
social engineering and fishing
>> it is mostly the same cognitive biases
uh but I I will say there's about 182
different cognitive biases and we do see
uh the biases that are used in email
aren't 100 they don't 100% align with
what's used maybe over the phone. Um
there's definitely overlap like the most
common or two most commonly used ones
are uh urgency uh and authority but we
see a lot of other different types of
attacks. And so there is a little bit of
a difference between what's done over
the phone and what's done uh through
email, but they all fall into these 182
biases that everybody uses every day.
And so it's it's not so much that uh so
much of a difference that we're not
going to be able to prevent it. And one
study that uh that I saw found that when
users go through a simulation, they are
over 70% less likely to fall for that
same type of attack regardless of what
medium it is. Um and that was what I
found really interesting. So let's say
that it's that, you know, CEO scam where
somebody's impersonating the CEO and
targeting them via text message. If they
get a call later that week from somebody
pretending to be the CEO, they are now
70% less likely to fall for it even
though the initial one came in over
text. And how often and and what is the
I guess the burn rate, I'm not sure if
that's the right term, but I'll use it
anyways. the the burn rate of a of the
cognitive ability to maintain that that
level of awareness because I would
imagine that a week into the
conversation you'd be much more
effective at at retrieving that that
that
subconscious area that you spoke about
before the thinking fast and slow rather
than if let's say a month from now it
happened a lot has happened within that
month that transpired how what have you
seen is sort of the right time, how
frequently you would have to do that
training in order for the employees to
stay alert with their biases.
>> Well, I'm a big advocate of continuous
training at least once every week. Um
and and I built our AI platform around
that methodology and and we're seeing uh
results that go against all of the
academic publications that are coming
out right now that and have been coming
out for a few years stating that
traditional awareness provides zero uh
risk reduction in terms of fishing
susceptibility.
um ours uh across the board, our clients
that have been on our system for more
than 12 months, their most susceptible
departments to fishing are the least
engaged in training. And and what that
proves is that the short, you know, less
than one minute style training is
actually effective at changing behavior.
So I would argue we need to be in front
of people every single week of the year.
Now, I would also argue we need to be
fishing them very regularly, too,
because that's how we identify when, you
know, they've they've relapsed or, you
know, when we've burnt through all of
their available retention and when
they've become more susceptible. And the
example or or analogy I like to use here
is when you drive to work in the
morning.
Uh most of the time, 99% of the time,
it's, you know, there's nothing that
happens. You don't have any close calls.
And that day, if anything, makes you
more and more complacent. But then that
1% of the time you have a close call,
somebody slams on their brakes in front
of you, somebody almost, you know,
sideswipes you, whatever it happens to
be. And now all of a sudden you're
hypervigilant. And that hypervigilance
doesn't just last that day, but you stay
vigilant for weeks to come. And to me,
that is the role of fishing at
simulations is to ensure that we capture
that relapse. We remind them that they
have to be more vigilant and as because
of that, they have that close call in a
safe environment versus with actual fish
that are trying to compromise our
company.
Makes total sense and you know we've
been focusing a lot on the uh on the
employee end and what you've found to be
most effective in the context of of the
employees and uh and and you're speaking
from years years of experience and I
don't know if you've kept track of how
many
>> hundreds of millions of fishing
simulations.
>> There you go. Um I'm I'm curious to hear
now from from the business perspective
of the enterprise the organization that
is coming to you and inter and engaging
with it and saying listen Joshua we you
know we we realize fishing is is rising
sharply. We realize it's a top threat to
organization. Every CEO I speak to says
fishing is not in the top five
priorities. It's in the top three
priorities of our organization. We
realized that one bad fishing scam can
take down an entire business unit,
damage reputation, create financial
fraud transfer, get create be the entry
point for ransomware, cyber attack, and
the list goes on. So the awareness is
there. What what is what did they find
most effective? Because I also realized
they use a variety of different
techniques to combat this.
what sounds to be like more of the
detection front like what you're coming
out with next year in the context of the
the alerts to the awareness and training
what what is the reception you're
getting from the from the enterprises
themselves and how are they experiencing
the evolution of the sophistication of
fishing and social engineering
>> so I think the most
I I guess the most dangerous factor
that that they're all seeing right now
is a shift from generic fishing to
what most people would argue is I say
most people because I've had some people
that don't think it's AI uh but most
CISOs I talked to in the Fortune 50,
Fortune 100 space, they they heavily
heavily believe they're being targeted
by AI. Why? because all of a sudden the
fish have gone from uh this generic fish
that promises money or scares you about
your password or whatever to contextual
fishing that tries to exploit your
day-to-day operations and procedures.
And so this contextual fishing knows
that you're in finance, knows who your
boss is, knows that you're in IT, knows
who your boss is. And so it's much much
more intelligent. Um the the way they're
using this for invoice fraud is that
they get into this conversation. maybe
they they actually get a you know
compromise somebody's email and then uh
they will send this email that goes back
and forth between the CEO or CFO of the
company or even just your boss and a
vendor that looks very very legitimate
that is something you would normally
buy. It's all works within your normal
business process and that conversation
between your boss and this vendor say
has your boss is the whole sales cycle
and you see it in the conversation will
say hey here's the cost here's the
pricing here's the value and then your
boss will say yeah I want to buy it send
me the contract and then the final
thread will be hey we need to collect
who do we contact and the boss says yeah
contact this person and it goes to you
the trick is is that was never your boss
But because they're faking a
conversation, it looks perfect and it's
as if they've done a perfect spoof. So
the level of sophistication is much
higher than it ever was. And they are
fishing us according to our role. And
the only way we're going to be able to
defend against that is to a fish our
users according to their role to train
and condition them against these types
of attacks. But B, we need to have that
role-based training. Hey, you're in
finance. You're going to be targeted
with these types of attacks. You're in
IT, you're going to be targeted with
these types of attacks. Oh, and by the
way, you need to avoid these common
mistakes that many IT professionals make
or many finance professionals make. And
so it's really shifting from that
oneizefits-all, everybody gets the same
thing to this more granular roles based
uh approach to both training as well as
fishing. And it's it's both from an
offensive and a defensive perspective.
Unfortunately, I will say that this is
one of those areas that the bad guys are
ahead of us on and their adaptation of
generative AI is just so much quicker
than the cyber security industry. Now,
being an AI tech founder, I'll tell you
why. It's because we can't have a
hallucination tell our users to go and
kill themselves. Um, I I make a joke,
but that happened last week. I don't
know if you saw the news
>> with a character AI.
>> Uh, Google Gemini,
this uh guy was talking to it about
elder abuse scams and uh and the entire
thread is available on Gemini for you to
read. And uh and the guy just keeps
asking the same question over and over
again until I guess the AI got annoyed
or something because it responded by
saying, "You're worthless. Everybody
hates you. Go kill yourself."
No joke. And there was no prompting to
get it to go there. It just came out of
nowhere. Um, so you know the the tech
companies understand that we don't we
cannot afford to have these sorts of
things happen other than maybe Google
since it happened on their watch. Um,
but Google jokes aside, it uh it's the
bad guys don't care if they have a a
hallucination. The bad guys don't care
if something misfires. The bad guys
don't care if they accidentally leak
sensitive information to the wrong
people. So the good guys do, but it
causes us to move so much slower than
the bad guys, and that's the reason
we're perpetually behind.
So Joshua, to wrap things up, if there
was one recommendation you would give to
employees that are that want to be at
the forefront of defending themselves
from social engineering and fishing
attacks, what would that be?
>> Trust your gut. Uh, I don't think enough
training goes into
the reality that our subconscious is our
built-in defense mechanism. And when we
feel like something's off, it's almost
always our subconscious warning us. And
yet, too often we don't listen to it. I
have not been involved in a single
instance or incident where the user that
let them in the network didn't say, "I
knew something was off. I should have
trusted my instincts. Um, that's what
users need to realize is that they do
have a builtin anti virus. It is very
intelligent. It's probably the best in
the world and all they have to do is use
it. And that means trusting their gut.
And the number one piece of advice to
CISOs, business owners that want to help
protect their employees from social
engineering and fishing.
>> Uh, as much as you can throw out the
stick. Um, using sticks over carrots has
been proven a million times over in
behavioral science to be ineffective. I
know there are some uh leaders in this
space that still advocate for the stick,
but they are very wrong. That adage, you
catch more flies with honey than with
vinegar, is is more true than you could
possibly realize. And I really do see a
backlash coming from all of the punitive
uh well, punitive approaches that we see
in in corporate America. And we've
already started to see wrongful
termination suits from people being
fired over fishing simulations. I know
not because they're uh our clients are
seeing them, but because we have clients
coming to us because we're the friendly
security awareness training and telling
us about how they just got sued and they
just lost this much money because of
that.
>> And and what's the difference from a
user? How do you make it friendly from a
user experience perspective? How do you
get because I would imagine that for
somebody falling for a social
engineering or fishing simulation that
must be pretty pretty hard moment or
pretty embarrassing moment especially if
you know that you know you're going to
be next up on the dashboard of the CISO.
How how do you how do you then mitigate
a real simulation that gets to the
moment of I guess attack with the with
the mitigating and and actually leaving
the employee feeling empowered by this.
So number one, we take every opportunity
we have to praise that user and tell
them how great they're doing. When they
report a fishing simulation uh or a real
fish, that's an opportunity to praise
them. yet most organizations aren't
praising them. When they don't click on
a fishing simulation, that's an
opportunity to praise them. So, I I
think we've got to focus more on praise
and less on telling people when they
mess up. But the other part is we gify
it. And uh and so at least with our
users, we tell them, hey, there's this
type of attack that uh or fishing attack
that pretends to be from your benefits
department or from your HR team or from
your finance team. And then it says,
"Now be on the lookout because the next
time you see it, it may be the real bad
guys or it could be us trying uh running
a simulation." And so what happens is
now if they fall for it, they were
already warned. We're not going to
exploit them. So the second they click,
they realize it's a mistake. And uh and
so it becomes less of a, oh man,
they're, you know, they're trying to
fire me or they're trying to use inside
information to trick me. It it almost
feels like this abuse of trust when you
do it without warning them. But when you
tell them you're going to do it, it's
now a game. Ah, you almost got me or
maybe you did get me. Um, and and it and
because of that, it doesn't have as much
teeth. But the other part that I I
mentioned there is do not exploit your
users. Now, if I'm running a penetration
test against your organization, I'm
going to have a login form there, uh,
you know, on the other side of that fish
to see if they'll type in their
credentials. But that is for a risk
assessment. Most security awareness
training we do and most fishing we do is
for the purpose of training and
empowering and bettering our people,
which means if we're exploiting them,
we're missing out on our best
opportunity to train the moment that
mistake is realized. And uh and I mean
you cannot I I don't even know how to
emphasize just how effective just in
time training is. And uh and so when you
exploit the user instead of giving them
that just in time training, you've
thrown away your best opportunity to get
that user to listen.
>> I love it. Joshua, thank you so much for
the time and for the energy and the
insights. loved every minute of this
conversation
>> and uh really best of luck with the with
the awesome work that you're doing and
I'm excited to keep in touch. Thank you.
>> Absolutely. And uh yeah, I'd love to
circle back uh we could do a whole
episode just on all the crazy uh
technological advancements we've seen in
the last uh what 6 months
>> in the last week. Absolutely.
>> That's true.
>> Did you hear about the photon processor?
>> Oh my god. That's for another episode.
Yes.